crétin de cerveau un ouais pour ceux qui
auraient raté le premier épisode crétin
de cerveau c'est une petite série de
vidéos que je vais consacrer à ce qu'on
appelle lé biais cognitifs toutes ces
situations où on commet des erreurs de
jugement où on prend des décisions
stupides irrationnel dans le premier
épisode je vous avais parlé de l'effet
de halo le fait qu'on attribue plein de
qualité de personnalité à des gens juste
sur la base de leur apparence physique
le deuxième effet dont on va parler
aujourd'hui s'appelle l'effet d'ancrage
pour comprendre ce que c'est que l'effet
d'ancrage on va faire un petit quizz
ensemble alors première question à votre
avis est-ce qu'une baleine bleue adultes
mesure plus de 49 m alors je vous laisse
répondre oui ou non
et puis deuxième question à votre avait
une baleine bleue sa mesure combien si
on fait ce petit quiz à un grand nombre
de personnes la moyenne des réponses
qu'on obtient à la deuxième question
c'est 60 m par contre si on pose
directement la deuxième question sans la
première c'est à dire qu'on demande
simplement à des gens d'estimer la
taille d'une baleine
ils vont répondre en moyenne 30 mètres
soit deux fois moins
c'est quand même bizarre c'est quand
même la même question pourquoi est ce
qu'il ya une telle différence entre les
deux situations
maintenant la première situation on a
commencé par poser la question de
manière ferme et en proposant à chiffrer
en demandant une réponse par oui ou non
et ce chiffre il crée ce qu'on appelle
un ancrage c'est-à-dire qui force les
gens à réfléchir dans une certaine gamme
de valeur et du coup à la deuxième
question qui cette fois est une question
ouverte
ils vont donner des réponses différentes
de ce qu'ils auraient donné si on leur
avait posé directement cette deuxième
question et du coup a dans ce cas précis
ils vont se planter complètement parce
qu'en fait trente mètres c'était à peu
près la bonne réponse mais 60 m à ces
deux fois trop alors quelque part on
pourrait penser que ce phénomène est un
petit peu normal à partir du moment où
l'on propose un chiffre dans la première
question et qu on part du principe que
celui qui nous posent les questions le
fait de manière un peu intelligente
il est légitime de prendre ce chiffre
comme un indice est donc c'est normal
que ça influence notre réponse à la
deuxième question
sauf qu'il ya deux expériences qui
viennent contredire cette explication
la première c'est le fait que les faits
d'ancrage fonctionne aussi si le chiffre
de la première question il est tiré au
hasard dans cette expérience elle a été
faite par daniel kahneman et amos
tversky qui sont deux psychologues
israélo américain qui sont un peu les
références mondiales en matière de biais
cognitifs
alors retenez bien leur nom parce qu'on
va en parler souvent dans crétin de
cerveau kahneman a d'ailleurs reçu le
prix nobel d'économie pour l'ensemble de
leurs travaux à faire ce qui bat il n'a
pas eu parce qu'il a eu la mauvaise idée
de mourir quelques années avant
revenons-en l'expérience l'idée c'était
de demander à des gens d'estimer combien
il y avait deux pays africains dans le
monde
en pourcentage du total en utilisant
comme tout à l'heure d'abord une
question fermée puis ensuite une
question ouverte et on a fait de la
manière suivante on fait tourner devant
chaque personne une roue numérotée de 0
à 100 et quand la roue s'arrête sur un
chiffre on utilise ce chiffre comme
ancre dans la première question
par exemple si la route on sur le
chiffre 10 devant les gens on leur
demande
y at il plus ou moins de 10% de pays
africains dans le monde
ça c'est la question fermée et puis
ensuite on leur pose la question ouverte
bas à votre avis combien il ya de pays
africains et en fait pour bien mettre en
évidence l'effet d'encre cette
expérience elle a été faite avec une
roupie étaient truquées et qui tombait
toujours soit sur dix soit sur 65
alors on va voir les résultats donc le
premier groupe à qui on demandait
d'abord à votre avis est il plus ou
moins de 10% de pays africains
au final il a estimé en moyenne qui
avait 25 % de pays africains dans le
monde est le deuxième groupe qui lui
était ancré avec le chiffre 60 5%
il a estimé qu' en avec 45% donc même
avec un chiffre dans crash qui a été
tirée au hasard devant leurs yeux cap a
été choisi par celui qui pose la
question et bien les gens ont été
influencé de manière vraiment
significatif dans leurs réponses et ya
encore plus fort non seulement on est
capable de se faire encrer par des
chiffres qui ont été tirés au hasard
devant nos yeux
mais on peut aussi se faire en créer par
des chiffres qu'on sait être totalement
absurde par exemple l'expérience avec la
taille de la baleine elle a été fait
avec les ancrages suivant un premier
groupe on a demandé pensez vous qu'une
baleine fait plus ou moins que 20 cm et
puis pour un autre groupe on a demandé
pensez vous qu'une baleine fait plus ou
moins de 900 mètres et ensuite comme
d'habitude pour les deux la question
ouverte
à votre avis c'est quoi la taille d'une
baleine est bien à cette question les
gens du premier groupe ont estimé la
taille moyenne d'une baleine à 20 mètres
donc trop bas et ceux du deuxième groupe
à 142 m donc même si je vous pose une
question en utilisant une encre
complètement absurde dont vous savez
pertinemment qu'elle est complètement
fausse ça va quand même vous influencer
c'est dingue un crétin de cerveaux sains
et il ya une autre observation qui à la
fois amusante et inquiétante
c'est que plus on utilise un chiffre
précis comme encre plus l'effet
d'ancrage va être puissant on a demandé
à un groupe ii
en d'estimer la valeur d'une maison une
belle maison sur une plage californienne
sur laquelle le prix était déjà affiché
donc pour un premier groupe de gens on
leur montrait la maison avec un prix
affiché de huit cent mille dollars et
ils l'ont estimée en moyenne en dessous
à 751 mille dollars
et puis on a refait l'expérience avec
d'autres gens mais cette fois avec un
prix affiché de la maison de 799 1800
dollars c'est un prix bien précis et
cette fois l'estimation moyenne ça a été
784 mille dollars un prix plus proche du
prix initialement affichées sur la
maison c'est à dire que l'effet
d'ancrage a été plus fort ce qui se
passe dans nos crétins de cerveau c'est
que plus le chiffre initial et précis
plus on est forcé à raisonner proche de
ce chiffre pour faire nos propres
estimations
donc bon moral de l'histoire quelques
petits conseils si vous êtes dans une
négociation premièrement soyez le
premier à proposer un chiffre histoire
d'encre et l'autre personne
deuxièmement proposer un chiffre bien
précis et puis troisièmement n'hésitez
pas à proposer un chiffre complètement
irréaliste
d'ailleurs à la fin de cette vidéo ceux
qui le souhaitent peuvent me soutenir
sur tipi en me laissant par exemple un
type de 480 7,92 euros
voilà c'était pour les faits d' ancrage
j'espère que le fait d'avoir
connaissance de ce biais cognitifs vous
permettra dans une certaine mesure d'y
échapper un petit peu et puis surtout
n'oubliez pas que tout ça a été étudié
scientifiquement on n'est pas dans la
psychologie de comptoir là je vous ai
mis d'ailleurs les références des
publications scientifiques
pour moi ces travaux en psychologie et
en sociologie sont vraiment essentiel et
il mériterait d'être mieux connues et
dans les prochains épisodes de la série
on verra encore plein d'autres biais
cognitifs qui font que notre cerveau est
vraiment un crétin si vous voulez aller
plus loin sur toutes ces questions deux
chaînes que je vous recommande qui
traite de thèmes un petit peu similaire
la première c'est la tronche-en-biais
qui parle notamment de biais et la
deuxième c'est hygiène mentale qui vous
aidera à développer votre esprit
critique et souvent on en a besoin
merci d'avoir suivi cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à la partager notamment
sur les réseaux sociaux pour faire
connaître les biais cognitifs et puis
pour m'aider à faire connaître
vous pouvez vous abonner bien sûr pour
ne rien rater vous pouvez suivre l'actu
de la chaîne sur facebook twitter et
ceux qui le souhaitent peuvent soutenir
surtout qui s'est beaucoup à tous les
skippers même s'ils doivent pas 480 7,92
euros et habib vous pouvez aussi aller
jeter un oeil à mon poids que j'ai sorti
chez flammarion voilà merci et à bientôt